[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
esta vez escala en parís sale de sus
estudios y se ubica en el corazón mismo
de parís estamos en un restaurant
cargado de gran historia que se llama ni
más ni menos este restaurant brazil
granca gran corazón y con un invitado de
excepción
mauro colagreco mauro muchísimas gracias
por aceptarlos y recibirnos en esta
segunda casa
un placer recibirlo ya que en el centro
mismo de de parís en mi segundo padre
sino como se dice mi segunda casa aquí
en francia un lugar hermoso sino
historia calmo
estamos en el corazón de parís pero no
los sentimos con exacto como en parís
mauro nació usted en argentina en la
plata hace poco más de 40 años llegó
usted a parís en francia también hace ya
20 años ya ha desarrollado desde
entonces una carrera fulgurante lo voy a
resumir de manera muy breve vamos a
decir que usted ha logrado obtener hoy
en día ni más ni menos la calificación
de ser el mejor chef tener el mejor
restaurante del mundo esto apenas en tan
sólo 20 años y además hay que decir que
también obtuvo usted ya las tres famosas
estrellas de la guía misión que
representa eso para usted
y es una verdad que es una carrera como
tú has dicho fulgurante
todo ha sucedido a una velocidad
increíble representa mucho para mí como
extranjero llegado en francia con donde
la gastronomía es tan tan importante
pero no es tan apreciada y son muy
orgullosos de su cocina y lo tienen
tienen por qué pero como sudamérica no
haber podido desde mi lugar representar
en nuestro continente nuestro hermoso
continente y poder aportar una visión
quizás diferente
y bueno y también en lo personal poder
haberle dado tantas alegrías a mi a mi
familia
y hacerlos sentir orgullosos y sentirme
orgulloso de mi trabajo de mis equipos
de mi familia mi mujer que me acompaña
de origen brasileño de origen brasileña
ella también sudamericana donde trabaja
actualmente está en mira sur nuestro al
hablaremos del instante en nuestro
restaurante al sur de francia así es
mauro una pregunta que es obligada vamos
a decir una especie de aperitivo como
entrada pero aunque ha causado no poca
indigestión para mucha gente cómo ha
vivido usted el confinamiento por causa
de coronavirus
y un momento calculo que como muchos no
muy angustiante en la primera etapa
sobre todo donde
cerrar todos nuestros restaurantes de un
día para el otro
fue un shock no saber hacia dónde íbamos
que iba a pasar qué ayudas íbamos a
tener cómo íbamos a hacer con nuestros
empleados
qué iba a pasar simplemente no eso fue
fue muy difícil unas primeras semanas
luego entrar en un momento donde tuve la
suerte de estar confinado en el sur de
francia donde mi casa está pegada al
huerto de uno de los huertos de mira sur
y entonces a la frontera política muy
cerquita el restaurante está a 50 metros
de la frontera y yo vivo a 300 metros
del restaurante así que bueno eso me
permitió estar más cerca de la familia
con un trabajo tan tan un ritmo tan tan
fuerte no que el que llevamos los
cocineros y más en la posición en la que
me encuentro no me ha
me ha servido para mucho para
reflexionar en lo personal pero también
en lo profesional decíamos ya que usted
en el año 2000 a francia y si usted me
lo permite trataré de hacer un resumen
muy apretado de lo que es un recorrido
verdaderamente extraordinario decíamos
con menos de 30 años con algunas
palabras de francés
supongo que menos dinero aún si william
en apenas cinco años después habré usted
ese restaurante va a convertirse en una
famoso internacionalmente en mira sur
cinco meses seis meses después usted
recibe ya la primera el primer
reconocimiento internacional que es la
revelación del año de vic de la guía wok
miller poco después y a partir de ahí
decíamos salvo el año 2014 cada año ha
recibido un premio internacional hasta
que en el 2019 obtiene el mejor chef del
mundo el mejor restorán del mundo
construir eso cómo se hace cómo se
elabora esa esa ciencia ese sabor esa
filosofía de ir construyendo un proyecto
que lo lleva hasta donde está hoy en día
si la verdad que fue se fue construyendo
día a día año a año sin
ninguna otra pretensión de ser un
restaurante que funcione con el cual
podía vivir esa fue la ilusión inicial
luego las cosas se fueron se fueron
sucediendo hemos tenido hemos estado en
el lugar justo en el momento justo no
con un poco de suerte
con mucho trabajo mucho sacrificio y
sobre todo una tensión por el detalle
por querer hacer las cosas bien no y la
pasión de querer hacer las cosas bien y
eso fue lo que nos fue llevando hacia la
excelencia y asia quizás no focalizarse
sólo en una rentabilidad no de un
restaurante de una empresa pero sino
también en lo que hablábamos un poco
anteriormente las otras riquezas no que
son las riquezas de espirituales la es
riqueza de poder recibir la gente sin no
sin otra intención de hacerle pasar un
momento excepcional no
y esos valores fueron los que nos
llevaron hacia hacia eso y obviamente un
trabajo de equipo muy importante
hoy por hoy somos 68 personas que
trabajan para servir 45 cubiertos muchos
personal mucho personal en francia es
enorme enorme y
y bueno cuando piensas que en 2006
cuando abrí el restaurante
éramos tres en cocina y dos en sala ni
siquiera un equipo de fútbol clara ni
siquiera un equipo de fútbol quiero
hablar de lo que usted habla como
riqueza me permito citar lo que usted
escribió captar la delicada
correspondencia entre los paisajes
percibir la música particular de las
estaciones y tratar de evocar esta
belleza en un plato es el trabajo
maravilloso que nos permite realizar
nuestro oficio es una declaración de
amor a la naturaleza a su profesión
sí yo creo en nuestra profesión es algo
maravilloso porque nos acerca al
producto no uno
un cocinero a la base es un manipulador
de productos no y para poder bien
manipular el producto uno lo tiene que
conocer y conociendo lo empieza a
encontrar el encanto de como con las
personas no uno más las cuales conoce
más encanta no
desilusiona parientes pero lo con la
naturaleza a uno no se desilusiona no
con la naturaleza uno se va enamorando
cada vez más y hablando de naturaleza
precisamente una de las cosas que usted
ha desarrollado tanto en miracruz como
aquí en la gran que es la permacultura
es la cosmos y na hablemos un poco de
esto
sí bueno el trabajo en los huertos de
mira sur
remón remonta y habla con tractor ya que
usted tiene si ya tenemos 5 hectáreas
hemos comenzado al inicio con sólo el
pequeño jardín que tenía que contaba el
restaurante y luego bueno este
enamoramiento con la naturaleza me ha
llevado a ir
tomando y recuperando otros terrenos es
cerca del restaurante y desde el inicio
prácticamente trabajamos envío luego
radicalizamos un poco más y nos fuimos
transformando a una cultura totalmente
natural sin ningún uso de agroquímicos o
pesticida llevándola hacia la
permacultura y la biodinámica y con el
trabajo de la biodinámica
comenzamos a estar más sensibles y
acercarnos más a lo que las culturas
antiguas
durante siglos y milenios
de observar
simplemente la naturaleza es observar el
cosmos qué influencia tienen los astros
sobre la tierra
cosas que hemos llegado al punto de
estar
de no estar más conectados al punto de
casi negar las no que existen y bibi y
eso es una pena y entonces bueno durante
el confinamiento hicimos un cambio
totalmente radical decidí de cambiar
totalmente la propuesta no totalmente
porque es el mismo estilo pero de llevar
realmente ese trabajo del huerto al
restaurante y realizar está cosmo cocina
que nos seguía por las fases lunares
para la fase lunar es exactamente perdón
que lo interrumpa para que nuestro
público lo entienda justamente el
submenú hoy está basado siguiendo esas
fases lunares en un vengo que se basa en
las raíces en las hojas en los frutos en
las flores según y dependiendo de cada
momento claro y esta fase lunar es
cambian cada 2-3 días
y nosotros cambiamos totalmente el menú
cada 23 días siguiendo este ritmo de la
naturaleza donde el menú va a estar
guiado por las raíces
obviamente no no no comen el menú no es
integralmente raíces pero pero tiene una
guía que son las raíces o las flores o
las hojas o los frutos
mauro el tiempo se va yendo muy
rápidamente llegará el clima es donde
usted ha llegado lo dijo en un principio
y en cinco esfuerzos fracasos tensiones
desilusiones cuál es su próxima meta
es una buena pregunta no creo que la la
meta
sigue siendo la misma no sé
siendo esa de querer
seguiré enamorándose de la naturaleza y
seguir haciendo esta hermosa profesión
con tanta pasión como el primer día
enamorado de la naturaleza enamorados de
la cocina gastronómica
estamos van llegando ya al final de este
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle a mauro colagreco primer
chef y primer cocina en el mundo su
invitación había aceptado abrirnos las
puertas de este su restaurant gran que
aquí en parís y también en mira sur allá
en el sureste de francia a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita la próxima semana
en otra escala en parís
[Música]